- Welcome back, y'all.
We are here with Eva Longoria.
Give it up.
(distant audience cheering)
So Eva's new movie is
called "Flamin' Hot".
It's the story about the
creation of a certain flavor
of a certain tasty chip snack.
And to celebrate the movie,
we've got a new game dedicated
to all things hot.
It's called Hot Enough for You?
(Eva laughing)
Yeah, that's my bedroom voice.
You're welcome.
(distant audience applauding)
Let's get a host down here.
Lord, what do you say?
Will you help us out?
(background artists ethereal vocalizing)
Yes,...
yes.
- [Game Announcer] Well, hey, Kelly.
I am here.
Sorry about that.
You, you caught me in the middle
of practicing pickle ball.
(distant Kelly chuckling)
It is...
That's a really hard game.
How you doing Kelly?
How you doing Dama Longoria.
- Ah, there we go.
- [Game Announcer] That's right.
- Thank you, darling.
- [Game Announcer] Nice
to see you, your highness.
Okay, that's enough of that.
Listen up, we got a game here.
And today, the answer to
each clue I'll give you is
something hot.
Could be hot tamales, could be hot dates,
could be a hot supreme being.
You get the idea.
You know what I'm talking about.
(Kelly chuckling)
But what you're gonna do
now is you're gonna hit your
button, and answer if you know.
If you're right,...
(background bell chiming)
you're going to hear that.
- Okay.
- [Game Announcer] But if you're wrong,...
(background buzzer ringing)
the other person can steal.
- That's what you're gonna hear.
- [Eva] That's what you're gonna hear.
- [Game Announcer] That's right.
Well, let's see what happens, ladies.
Okay, now Eva, you're
playing for your side
of the audience,...
(distant audience cheering)
and Kelly is playing for her side.
There you go.
Make some noise.
(distant audience applauding)
- Oh, there's a prize.
- Yes.
- [Game Announcer] Oh, there is a prize.
There's a pretty hot
prize on the line too.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Game Announcer] See what I did there,
see what I did there?
- I did, I saw.
- [Game Announcer] Okay,
here is your first question.
- Okay.
- [Game Announcer] If you're
looking to sweat while doing
a little downward facing dog...
- Oh...
(background tone beeping)
(Eva chuckling)
- In your face, hot yoga.
(background bell chiming)
- [Game Announcer] It's hot yoga.
(distant audience cheering)
You got it.
- Downward dog...
- [Game Announcer] Downward dog.
- It was, was it bikram?
- [Eva] Yep, it hot yoga.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Game Announcer] That's right.
We all been there doing that downward dog.
I'm more of a, uh, more of
a mountain pose guy myself.
- Okay.
- [Game Announcer] But
mostly 'cause I made them.
Okay, here's the next one.
- Oh my God.
- [Game Announcer] These colorful
air crafts can famously...
(background buzzer ringing)
Okay, go ahead.
- Hot air balloons.
- [Game Announcer] It is hot air balloons.
Unbelievable.
(distant audience cheering)
- What?
- [Game Announcer] That's right.
That was so quick.
Hot air balloons, also
something you might see
while you're doing yoga.
Okay.
Here's your next, here's your next one.
(Kelly chuckling)
I'll give you a minute.
Okay, if you are the rapper, Nelly,
you enjoy encouraging people...
Kelly.
♪ It's getting hot in here
to take off all clothes ♪
- [Game Announcer] Hot in here.
- What's up?
- [Game Announcer] That is right.
- What's up, Eva?
- [Eva] You got one.
- [Kelly] What's up?
- You got one.
- I'm getting excited about my one.
(Eva laughing)
- [Game Announcer] Okay,
let's, let's move on.
Here's your next question.
Back in the early days
of the worldwide web,
you had your EarthLinks, your Prodigys,...
Kelly.
- You had Hotmail.
- [Game Announcer] Hotmail.
- [Eva] Oh!
- [Game Announcer] That's right.
- No idea.
- [Kelly] I'm back, I'm back.
- [Game Announcer] Oh, we
got ourselves a tie here.
- [Eva] And I'm that old,
I should've known that.
- [Kelly] I know.
I'm that old.
- [Eva] I think I had a hotmail.
- I'm forty.
- [Eva] Yeah. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm fortyish.
- [Kelly] I think I, yeah had a hotmail.
(distant audience chuckling)
- [Game Announcer] I still have a hotmail.
It's, uh,
loveitwhenyoucallmeBigPapa37@hotmail.
- I had hotmail.
- [Kelly] "Call me Big Papa."
- [Game Announcer] So, uh,
shoot me a message will ya?
Okay, here's your next question.
Now it's the nineties, and
we're heading to the mall.
You want to go there, and
drink some orange Julius,
maybe...
- Go to a Hot Topic.
- [Game Announcer] Go to a Hot Topic.
(background bell chiming)
- Oh!
- [Game Announcer] That's right.
- [Eva] What?
- I feel powerful!
- That was amazing.
I never would've gotten that.
And I shopped there.
- I feel powerful.
- [Eva] And I drank orange julius.
- [Game Announcer] Oh,
Kelly, that was good.
- I did too, orange...
- [Game Announcer] Kelly now
in the lead, now in the lead.
Hot Topic, that's where I get my...
- Oh my God.
- Hot Topic...
- [Game Announcer] That's
where I get my guyliner.
(distant audience laughing)
Okay, here's your next question.
These little pools are
basically nature's jacuzzis...
(background buzzer ringing)
- Oh, it's so sad.
Hot tub.
(distant audience laughing)
Hot springs!
(background buzzer ringing)
- [Game Announcer] It's not hot tub.
- Hot springs, hot springs!
- No!
- Hot springs. - I meant hot springs.
- [Game Announcer] It is hot springs.
I'm sorry, Kelly.
- [Eva] I was like hot tub?
- [Kelly] I meant hot springs!
I said hot tub.
- [Game Announcer] You see what happens?
- [Eva] I was like...
- Ah, nature, oh man.
- Nature, hot springs...
- My ego got me there, there you go.
- [Game Announcer] Yeah, it always does.
I enjoyed watching that.
You got cocky, girl, you got cocky.
- I know I did.
I'm calming down.
- [Game Announcer] Okay,
we still got a tie here.
Here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [Game Announcer] This
oxymoronically named ointment is
something you might...
(background bell ringing)
- [Kelly] What?
- Icy Hot.
- [Game Announcer] Oh, it's Icy Hot.
You got it.
(distant audience cheering)
- I got to be honest with you,
I forgot what we were even looking for.
(serious background tune chiming)
- [Game Announcer] Oh,
and that very serious
public domain music means it's
time for our last question.
- Okay, okay.
- [Game Announcer] This
one is worth five points.
- What?
- [Kelly] Yeah,
interesting,... - [Eva] What?
- interesting.
- [Game Announcer] Here
we go. - [Eva] That's...
- Oh, mother...
- [Game Announcer] This
delicious dessert comes with nuts
or without,...
(background buzzer ringing)
- Oh.
- [Game Announcer] Kelly.
- A hot fudge sundae.
- [Game Announcer] It's
a hot fudge sundae.
(distant audience cheering)
(background air horn honking)
- Very happy you won.
- Of course everyone is a winner
on the Kelly Clarkson Show,
y'all.
So, you are all going to
get to heat things up with
the Anova precision cooker.
The Anova sous vide kit used
by professionals for decades
works by circulating
heated water in a pot,
cooking food to the exact set temperature,
for perfect results every time.
You're welcome.
(distant audience excited cheering)